What I think the best answer is is that we're doing system or validation testing.
That is to say we're testing the whole system as a unit,
and we're trying it on some small subset of our users
to try to validate the fact that the changes we've made
are good and that they work and they're not going to cause any sort of major problems
when we roll it out for the entire user base.
We're not doing random testing because there's no random element here.
We're not doing differential testing because we don't
have multiple implementations of anything.
We have a single system that we're looking at.
We're not doing integration testing because the character of the testing
that we're doing here does not have the flavor of putting
multiple modules together that haven't been tested together previously.
Rather, we're rolling something out and seeing what happens.